no
[Música]
urbanas noches me da muchísimo gusto
estar el día de hoy con todos ustedes
para venir a platicarles una historia de
cómo comenzó el corporativo y de cómo se
pueden hacer las cosas cuando uno quiere
hacerlo cuando uno ama lo que hace
les quiero comentar
que tenía escasamente 18 años cuando
empezó este sueño
era tan solo un joven deseoso de hacer
las cosas de hacer el bien de procurar
siempre el bien común pero sobre todo
generar fuentes de empleo dignas para
las familias
mucha gente decía sergio
no se va a poder muchos chavos cuando un
servidor
estaba trabajando ellos se iban de
fiesta
y me decían al pobrecito
tiene una revista y no le va a ir bien
pero nunca decayó mi sueño
siempre luche por mis ideales
mucha gente dice no se puede hacer
ningún negocio si no tiene capital o
lana para poder hacer algo y yo creo que
lo más importante es amar con pasión lo
que uno quiere hacer es por ello de que
estoy aquí con ustedes compartiendo les
y diciéndoles que si se puede
siempre y cuando tengamos esta condición
presente
y queramos hacer las cosas con pasión
el 80% de la población del mundo
termina trabajando por necesidad
y el 20% de la población termina siendo
lo que ama compasión donde quieren estar
ustedes
haciendo las cosas que en verdad amas o
trabajando por necesidad
quiero compartirles algunos puntos que
son importantes tenemos que analizar muy
bien el plan de negocios de lo que
ustedes quieran hacer no pueden
adentrarse a la deriva
sin analizar los riesgos que puede uno
llegar a tener al momento de hacer un
negocio porque uno arriesga su capital y
en ocasiones arriesga
los ahorros que han hecho durante mucho
tiempo
creo importante que por eso se debe
analizar perfectamente qué es lo que
vayan a hacer
para que ese negocio sea fructífero
debemos analizar precisamente el público
a dónde quieren llegar
para poderles satisfacer las necesidades
pero sonia yo creo que lo más importante
que ustedes deben de analizar es
precisamente ver exactamente las
vocaciones los famosos llamados clusters
de los estados que competen a la
república mexicana o por qué no analizar
los productos que se vayan a mandar a
otros países
y claro que se puede porque tenemos
talento y se pueden hacer las cosas
obviamente también tenemos que ver los
financiamientos que existan en cada
momento en todas las áreas de
oportunidad tanto en gobierno tanto en
itunes bancarias o por qué no decirlo
con empresas que apuestan a
emprendimientos que pueden llegar a
generar
y pueden lograr hacer grandes empresas
tractoras
yo creo que lo más importante hoy en día
es generar empresas de vanguardia
hoy creo que tenemos absolutamente todo
si uno analiza el porqué y el cómo
muchas personas les quiero comentar que
me he topado al día de hoy y muchos
emprendedores que oportunidad platicar
con ellos
y desgraciadamente cuando generan una
empresa
se gastan el dinero
todos sus ingresos desgraciadamente los
invierten en otra cosa obtuvieron la
primera venta y lo primero que hicieron
se compraron absolutamente cosas que no
son para la inversión de las empresas
al día de hoy tengo 25 años generando
fuentes de empleo
y les quiero comentar que lo tengo por
ley
el 80 por ciento
está diversificado en un portafolio de
compra de materiales
obviamente inversiones
y el 20% lo utilizo para gastos
personales
hoy lo más importante y más si vas a
tener una empresa que va creciendo poco
a poco es un huevito que lo tenemos que
cuidar y lo tenemos que conducir para
llevarlo a buen puerto siempre toda la
vida deben de procurar por la
reinversión empresa que no reinviertan
empresa que está predestinada obviamente
a morir o al fracaso
obviamente es muy importante y se los
quiero comentar tenemos que aprovechar
absolutamente todas las oportunidades y
las bondades que la tecnología nos está
dando al alcance anteriormente
veíamos que el negocio de un comercio
local abría las puertas de su empresa y
si sólo se vendían lo que tenían la
oportunidad de vender en la cuadra la
oportunidad de venderlo en la ciudad
en la región pero hoy gracias al
internet con las páginas de internet
tenemos esa bondad de poder ofertar
nuestros productos de calidad generando
valor y obviamente entregando productos
de calidad
absolutamente en cualquier parte del
mundo
hoy vivimos en un mundo globalizado en
donde vemos que algunos otros países
han absorbido muchísimo las ventas que
posiblemente veíamos que generaban en
nuestro país
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
apostarle crear buenos productos
para que para que el día de mañana
puedan ustedes ver productos sus
productos en otras partes del mundo
quiero compartirles también
que algo que es muy importante y también
lo he platicado es que quiero invitar a
la gente a que esté dentro de la
formalidad dentro de la legalidad
es muy importante que todas estas
empresas logren estar dentro de la
formalidad para poder crecer
para poder generar líneas de valor a
toda esa gente que trabaja contigo se la
rifa contigo y que obviamente lo que
desea es que el día de mañana puedan
tener una pensión
muchas personas hoy en día en cualquier
empresa que está dentro de la ilegalidad
o la famosa informalidad no tienen una
certidumbre
no tienen un modo de vida porque nunca
tuvieron oportunidad de sacar una casa
porque nunca tuvieron la oportunidad
tengo un fondo de ahorros
por qué no decirlo hay ocasiones que hay
personas que desgraciadamente pueden
tener una enfermedad y que no pueden
tener una atención digna médica porque
están dentro de la ilegalidad
que queremos dar queremos dar
certidumbre a los países para que
desarrollen para que puedan crecer
y obviamente es muy importante también
compartirles esto si nosotros
como empresarios como emprendedores
tenemos ese compromiso de pagarles
forzosamente un salario digno que pueda
dar merecimiento a las familias
estoy seguro que cualquier producto que
el día de mañana nosotros como
empresarios generemos al mercado
podrán comprar estas personas
no puede haber productos de alta calidad
y que el día de mañana tengamos una
gente que no pueda adquirir esos
productos
obviamente también es muy importante
compartir con ustedes
que debemos de analizar muy bien a las
personas que vayan a ocupar cargos
direcciones
o puestos estratégicos en sus empresas
que sean altamente productivos que sean
altamente competitivos por qué no
decirlo
hay un gran corporativo refresquero a
nivel mundial
que tiene el great place to work porque
no buscar todas las empresas
donde en verdad busquemos que la gente
sea feliz trabajando allí y que se pone
la playera y que se la rifan
y que el día de mañana pueden seguir
creciendo
aportando al desarrollo
es por ello que yo quiero agradecerles
infinitamente e invitarlos a que nunca
dejen de soñar
que todo sueño se puede hacer realidad
siempre y cuando tenga cimientos siempre
y cuando ustedes lo quieran
le reitero
no es necesario tener dinero
si tu tienes esta convicción tienes muy
claros tus pensamientos y hacia dónde
quieres llegar estoy seguro que lo van a
lograr muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]